[Music]
hello everyone thank you for coming to
this talk today this is the final intern
talk by andrea andrea has been an inter
with us for this summer on this special
internship project on spatial audio he's
a PhD student at New York University and
he will be talking about blind room
volume estimation that Andrea please
Thank You anis all right thanks for
coming to my talk my the title for my
talk is towards real-time blind room
volume estimation from single channel
audio signals in noisy conditions and
the word towards here is important so
let's move to the outline so today I'm
gonna give some background on motivation
or why this project was fought in the
first place
some previous work and objectives that
we derived from literature our proposed
approach and we're gonna go through our
the data that we collected the features
that we decided to compute our
prediction model and the results then
finally we're going to discuss some
future works and improvements that could
be implemented some conclusions and
discussion so let's start from the
background so acoustic parameters why do
we care about them in mixed and
augmented reality virtual sources our
desired desire to be perceived as
fitting with the rest of the user
physical space so we want to mix reality
real sources and virtual saucers to
blend together in the same perceptual
space so this would improve auditory
plausibility spatial audio immersion
spatial audio quality so acoustic room
tailoring can be achieved by using a
room input response that is specific to
the spacing questions so we can measure
room impulse responses and that will
describe how does the sound behave for a
particular source receiver position is
inside the room and as you can see from
the image this is more or less the idea
that mixed reality wants to achieve so
you have a listener inside an
environment and you want the virtual
sound source to blend together with a
real sound source however room impulse
response is a very difficult
to measure the required technical
expertise so scientists have developed
synthesis methods they can use acoustic
parameters to model and input response
so as you can see from Friendly's image
I think most of you're familiar but I'm
gonna just give a brief overview there
reimpose responses emitted by the fuse
part which is independent of the
location the responses taken within a
room and by the first part there is a
direct sound an early reflection that
part is position dependent so going to
the use case of mixed reality we may
want to to create an adaptive algorithm
that can dynamically adapt to the
position of the user within a space so
here we can see for example a school and
there's some hololens users that wants
to move around from an auditorium it
moves to a corridor Danny moves to a
room moves back to an auditorium and
goes around the building each one of
these spaces there they sound very
different acoustically so it is
necessary to capture the parameters that
describe the local acoustic environment
in each one of these spaces separately
the challenges of this problem is that
blind estimations cannot make
assumptions over the local environment
where somebody is present at the time so
for example in this image we can see
many people wearing some sort of mixed
reality device and they are surrounded
by noise sources this babble north is
ambient noise perhaps is also a fan
noise and they might be all different
devices where some of them have multiple
microphones of them only on one
microphone maybe some of them of cameras
so we wanted to think about something
which is more generalizable and simple
for each one of these situations so our
approach was to think of situations
Safa cos generalizable as possible and
the the way we decide to go is for
single channel audio based estimations
blind estimation means there's we have
no prior knowledge of the space we have
no prior knowledge of the sources around
the listener or the geometry of the room
so previous work on acoustic parameters
as mostly focused on two main parameters
called reverberation time T 60 or the d
RR did arrive to reverberant ratio
there's quite a big body of literature
about black the blind prediction of
these two parameters and other
parameters have not been as covered as
much as the t 60 and the d RR
but the T 6 is basically the time it
takes for an impulse response to decay
down by 60 DB and the D RR is the
director reverent ratio that describes
the ratio between the first part and the
late part more recently literature has
proposed a different way to describe an
acoustic environment and that is by the
reverberation fingerprint so the
reverberation fingerprint is no other
than a frequency dependent T 60 DK
coupled with an initial power spectrum
and the room volume so at the beginning
of this internship we started looking at
T 60 and ER are thinking okay maybe we
can improve the what has been done in
the past so these are the results of the
eighth challenge in 2015 in back at the
time most metals were signal based there
was not much machine learning into these
into spatial audio
time so the best results were achieved
by sino processing methods and after
2015 and I mean the numbers don't really
matter in specifically but basically
octave spectral band based algorithms
were the best performing recently
machine learning approaches have
improved estimation of t60 so these are
the results from two papers one is from
Hannah's and another one is another
paper that came out this year and these
are two two approaches the use machine
learning to predict t60 and they showed
that quite an improvement from previous
method can be achieved so they both have
performed any of the algorithms in 2015
so this quiet was quite an interesting
thing to find because the these
approaches are quite new in spatial
audio and they are the first early
attempts but they seem to produce
already considerable improvements so we
kept this in mind as we went forward one
thing one thing to know that that we
took out of this is also that t60 is
almost a salt problem the current
literature shows really good results and
of course is possible to improve it but
we thought that there is the space to
try to compute something else
the drr on the other hand it's it's a
parameter that is source position
dependent so if you estimate the drr you
can estimate it for one particular
source but that doesn't tell you much
about other sources that you want to
render within the local environment so
instead we decided to to choose a
different parameter and that was room
volume so why room volume a room volume
as a parameter as an acoustic parameter
can serve as a proxy to obtain other
parameters
so for example the critical distance can
be described by a formula that includes
volume and also the initial power
spectrum that we saw from the energy
decay relief which was the T 60 decay
the initial power spectrum can be
adapted using a ratio of a reference
volume and a local volume and that work
has been also discussed during the aver
conference for some of those some those
who view the word there so it seems to
be something that right now people have
started to think about but there is very
little amount to literature about the
prediction of room volume so we decided
that this might be a good opportunity to
try something new and try to to see
what's possible to do using similar
approaches that have been used recently
4060 one question that we at the
beginning is whether we can hear volume
at all so these these audio examples
they show the dry signal convolved with
free impulse responses from three
different rooms where the T 60 was the
same but the volume was very different
so all the free examples they have a T
60 time of about one second but they are
different sizes in the rooms where they
were recorded there were all different
sizes so the first room was only 100
cubic meters second was 900 and the
third was 8,000 cubic meters so I try to
play the signals the problem is that
they're gonna go through speakers so you
we're gonna hear the volume of this room
on top of the volume of the room where
it was recorded this is the original
signal which was provided by Professor
Pookie
this is the small room
this is the medium room this is the big
room right so one of the end the small
room is clearly different to their song
perhaps some absorption coloration is
involved there to the medium and and the
big they're little they sound more
similar in this space but if you listen
them for red phones you can notice some
something different in the low
frequencies I just played them once more
so original small room
medium room and big room so that we
don't know I'm gonna get to that point
later but you know if you go back and
see the four critical distance yeah yeah
that's so that that's one of the
challenges we don't know the data that
we collected is mostly from data sets
who do not provide that information so
yeah this is this one one case examples
but the t60 is the same so they have a
similar perceptual quality the first
thing you notice about the room is how
burnt is it they are similarly
reverberant but the volume is different
so the probe their properties are
obviously different because they have
different volumes for the same became
time but the question is can I hear a
difference just based on that one
parameter changes which is important
right so just by listening these
examples we were think about what
possible representations could capture
this information and we're going to get
back to this in later slides so previous
work about blind volume estimation
there's not as much literature as 40 60
or drr it's kind of a it's being treated
as a side problem but recently it's been
brought up again in 2012 there was a
paper about room identification using
generalized linear mixture model
Gaussian mixture models and MFC sees the
problem with that paper is that this use
the same rooms in the training and the
test set and that as we can see later on
makes a big difference in your results
they they somehow achieved 23 percent
error rate equal error rate I think but
the way they divided for room sorry
input response location within the room
but having the same room in both sets
it's not really telling you much I think
I think I think Gaussian mixture model
yeah I think there's an L there for
sorry another paper by shapped I used an
abrupt speech detector in speech signals
to detect the end of a sentence of a
word and from that moment in time treat
whatever comes after as if it were an
impulse response
so whenever word was uttered the end of
the world especially after very sharp
consonants could be treated as if that
was the impulse response and by
selecting that time frame they would try
to estimate the volume also using a
Gaussian mixture models and but that
paper only looked at clean conditions so
free from noise that method was also
brought up again from in a recent paper
where they implemented the same method
and they and they trained it for a
regression model but they only tested
this method on a SM data so image source
method image source models so the image
source model creates a very clean
synthesized impulse response which works
well for shoebox rooms rectangular rooms
but on the other hand is not really
representative of real situations so
even there they trained something that
works in a theoretical model but there
was no test on actual rooms so this left
quite a few quite a big space for us to
try to come up with a regression model
that could try to estimate volume from
any type situation yes
so we have a source somewhere in the
room and the microphone we have no idea
where the source is for the microphone
news that we want to estimate about me
yeah so that that's that's the mode the
highest level of blindness that you can
achieve you don't know where you are you
don't know where the source is how many
sources there are if there's noise if
there's no noise we wanted to start with
the least amount of assumptions as
possible and then of course future work
and start making like side assumptions
and try to see semi-blind methods we're
gonna get that - that - all right so our
proposed approach is to detect room
volume blindly from signals using a
convolutional neural network and form
unframed
the problem is a regression problem so
we aim to simulate a variety of noisy
environment containing reverberant
speech within the environment and
represent as much range of room size as
possible and as much real impulse
response data as possible so the impulse
response are used to synthesize to
simulate SAR in the noisy environments
so we thought about training a network
from short single channel audio
recordings so four seconds long using
different snr levels so we simulate the
different ratios between the noise and
the speech the reverberant speech the
the main goal was to evaluate the
results to gain insights into the
problem and try to move forward from
there the fourth second extract is also
relevant for a real-time estimation so
although is not exactly real-time a
four-second chunk of audio is fairly
fast to evaluate and that that also part
of the requirements to mix reality as
somebody moves around the building so
this is the pipeline that we set in
place I'm going to talk about each one
of these steps we collected data we
synthesized also some data then we
we went on with the date documentation
simulated the noisy rooms made our sets
our training and the development and
evaluations sets we proceeded a feature
extraction we trained model we evaluated
the model and then the that would inform
us on how does how did the feature
perform in the model and then go back to
extract more features or change some
parameters so data
all right so data collection this was
definitely the most time-consuming part
of the internship where several weeks
were spent into retrieving online
datasets public datasets and format them
into something that could be given to a
network so we found eleven public room
APIs response data sets and two internal
data sets we only were interested in
rooms for which we add room volume
information so this proved a challenge
as in just a time-consuming challenge to
prune each data set from the entries
which did not have that information we
had to do some custom information
retrieval to to associate that
information correctly clean up
inconsistencies parts into a single file
boring work but thank you assuming but
he at the end of the at the end of the
data collection we ended up with 84
unique rooms as you can see did they all
come from different places and their
worlds were sampled at different
sampling frequencies for some reason one
chose a sampling frequency of twelve
point seven 80 kilo Hertz it's kind of
odd lights for 1993 it's a bit old data
set so maybe the standards were not as
set as now we resampled all this data to
16 kilohertz I believe which is good
enough for speech signals so these are
some stats about DeRosa
we obtained so the first graphs shows
how many unique rooms per dataset we
were able to to extract this second plot
shows the room volume distribution on a
logarithmic scale so the logarithmic
scale wants to represent the fact that
differences between small rooms should
be treated differently that the same
difference in a larger scale so for
example a room that is 20 cubic meters
can be sound very different from room
that is 40 cubic meters but everyone
that is 2020 cubic meters probably does
not sound very different than a room
that is 2040 cubic meters so that's why
we're representing the the distribution
on a logarithmic scale as you can see
the the main problem there is that we
had a gap in the middle about available
room volumes in our data set which we
fixed a little bit through data
simulation and try to later on although
part of the gap still remained the last
graph on the right it's is just an
Instagram of the repetitions or takes
per room so the each one of these data
sets took different they're all
different in terms of how many positions
did they record what speakers the keeper
in did they use so some some data sets
have maybe hundreds of takes inside a
single room and some are this said I
only want ik inside room so as a result
the final distribution of how many
impulse response we have it's plotted on
the on the graph on the right and they
describe a bias towards these either
small rooms
office sides kind of room or very large
rooms because
the quite quite quite a few concert
halls in some of the data sets moving on
oh yeah then we decided to cap the
representation to 50 takes per unique
room so each unique room was represented
a maximum of 50 times so simulated data
so analysts managed to together with
nikunj to simulate 50 rooms using
randomly created polygons which were
shaped in a way to avoid very regular
rectangular rooms so these irregular
polygons create more realistic
geometries and they were the simulation
was setup for 100 random receiver
position inside is this model and the
triton was used to simulate impulse
responses for a range of volumes from 60
to more or less 3,000 cubic meters the
results of these models are band limited
to two kilohertz due to the way try to
works right now and this data was used
to make a parallel data set where we
could compare the effect of having
simulated rooms against not having
similar two rooms in training yes
yeah no simulated data was put into the
test set all in the train set right so
once once our data collection was
completed we moved on to the corpus
creation so this is a if you are
familiar with the ACE challenge this is
a pretty much the same setup where room
impose response to room impose responses
belonging to the same room we're taking
and one was convolved with a speech
extract
chosen and the other one was was convo
with either Babel noise or ambit noise
an SNR was chosen between four different
levels 0 DB + 10 DB plus 20 DB and
infinite meaning that no noise was was
included in some examples the signals
were added together and then it was
split into 4 second windows the speech
corpus you use it I guess has a certain
lesson at the great speech around 40 to
60 DB 60s to do quality yeah yes so
infinite is actually in relationship to
the noise that we had not to denote that
was a read in speech expert why did you
convert the noise
so - to make the noise belong to the
same room as the speech single single
direction of noise personal weird yep
that's that's like you place loudspeaker
in the room then you play that noise
yeah I I guess it's it's what it's a way
to to just set up a problem from from a
single channel perspective yeah I see I
see what should what you mean but having
a yeah in the end everything was single
channel so the idea it's it's it's to
try to come up with a simple model for
now and then aspect which is a little
bit the bird a little bit deeper in the
east challenge setup is that the the ace
challenge was recorded on a challenge
the corpus was generated by recording
actual noise in a real room and then
mixing it into signal and what we were
trying to do is generate training data
that would simulate that somewhat but
the ambient noise that was in these real
recordings isn't just some fan noise
somewhere there's when I listen to it at
least I heard that there is somebody
walking down the corridor case it was a
public space so they just recorded
whatever was happening so somebody's
walking down a corridor you can hear
elevator pings you can hear a door slam
somewhere so you have some transient
components in the ambient noise and so
the idea was that we generate something
that's similar to that type of ambient
noise but once you have these transients
in your signal you should come up with
with the with the with a impulse
response from the same room otherwise
you have anechoic anechoic noise mixed
into that you can do 60 of the room
where the noise you've been recording
quantity
voice yeah but the noise was simulated
sudden so what we did is we we had
shaped colored noise Gaussian noise
color Gaussian noise where the color
spectrum is kind of derived from from
some of the noise recordings so it's a
train noise dry noise and then added to
that some anechoic random impulsive
sounds like office equipment stuff for
footsteps things like that and then take
that and come over it with the impulse
response so that is transient components
our convo it is a smooth yeah it's a
it's a compromise but the thing is some
of the data sets only had one impulse
response and suddenly have two but we
couldn't afford to discard things just
because they when they when there were
more equal to sponsors available we used
more than just one to come up to
generate the noise that we used up to
form but not many of those recordings
have more than four or five impulse
responses so it's right after the this
process we ended up with a with a big
corpus of data that we needed to split
so we decided to split the development
and evaluation set using unique room IDs
so this by keeping track of the room
where every signal belong to we managed
to separate based on that the training
set from the test set so that we make
sure that the rooms present in the test
set do not appear at all in the training
stage so the test that comprises the
whole AC e challenge dataset which is a
good for to make resource more
comparable with with previous AC based
papers the training validation ratios in
the development set were set to 90 and
10% and we had two parallel sets with
and without the Triton simulations
as I said each room was represented
maximum 50 times we randomized if if a
room for example at 100 positions we
randomly chose 50 of them there was it
was not an ordered peak all right so
features looking at features something
we did recently is to look at the low
frequency FFT so when we arrived we
talked a little bit about what might
happen in the in the modes so the the
generative room would affect the
frequency and the intensity of the modes
over room so we tried to see if that
whether that was easily captured ball by
simple FFT processing so just by taking
but just by looking at the low frequency
FFT from 0 to 500 Hertz these are the
same rooms that we listen the audio
example from and it can already be seen
that a small room compared to the larger
rooms first of all as less very low
frequency content by the same time an
interesting thing to look is the
presence of notches and the distance
between the notches so in the smaller
room these are the way the way the the
frequency of the frequency magnitude
response it's has larger periods
compared to the bigger rooms so this is
something that could be captured for
example by a step strim which is the
last plot on the right which is trying
to capture how frequently these notches
are and how spaced apart they they are
represented you should the speed the
spectrum changes
most probably will not contain much
information about the tips right but if
the spectrum changes fast then I would
expect more deep stew that would got to
correlate with the presence of bigger or
more dips exactly peaks in dibs so so
that was part of some of the features
that we want to look at in the graph in
the middle just show some sorted FFT to
see what is the essentially the energy
in the in the low frequency bands and
you can see that the small room in blue
here the these x-axis does not mean much
because it is all resorted but you can
see a clear difference between us more
room and larger rooms but in this case
from the medial to the large is not much
that much of a difference P so what this
is really showing I guess is a smaller
number of frequency bins I come from
most of the energy on the blue yeah so
basically we take we take this this
thing and we store it for like higher
values to lower values right and this
can tell you if if there are many modes
in a room this curve will be flatter and
start earlier and this will result it's
easier to see when you plot it that way
it's not yeah yeah the door yeah exactly
exactly what Peter's the room that
flatter is the reason
actually it's say that the orange curve
is flatter than the others but it's
quite small difference so technically
you can do statistics over the frequency
axis like minimum maximum being various
in if you can go even the second order
statistics there definitely yeah there
is some ground to to work on that and
later on we speak more about features
the other the other main thing that we
wanted to look at this time frequency
representations so this is these are two
different representation one is the
gamma tone filter back if I'm correct
with er be Center frequencies and the
second plot is M FCC's so those are two
different ways to that are used in
neural networks to represent audio
signals in this case there are different
resolutions but idea it's that you can
have if you have a very fine
time resolution and not as we find the
frequency resolution although that can
be changed you can probably capture how
each frequency channel decays through
time and that could hold some good
information about these modes or just
frequency behavior in a room so actually
something to clarify the previous light
deserves this is from impulse responses
these are FFTs for impulse responses and
these are a time frequency
representation from speech signals all
right so we decided to combine all these
features in what we call the feature
stack we basically put together this
representation using a gamma tone filter
Bank FFT the sorted F of T the sub
strewn an envelope follower and a
low-pass time domain so that was the
result of the gamma tone filter Bank
applied with the resolution that we
wished so we're four four second speech
signal we had I think 64 bins time bins
of resolution with 32 bins of hop size
this resulted in 1991 time instances so
everything has was tailored to be just
the same size that can fit together into
a single network alright so prediction
model we started off from what was
already implemented for the T 60 problem
so this is from the people from Anna's
on even where six linear convolutional
neural network followed by a dropper
linear and fully connected layer result
into into the neural network that
actually produce improved results from
the AC challenge so we decide to start
from here and then work our way into
modifications to see what what yielded
the best results so by not being a
machine learning expert this was a good
place to start and and further explore
so this was tailored for a gamma Tony or
B filter back made of 21 filters and for
second Windows so that's also why which
was for second windows to be able to
just reuse this network easily this is a
different network that we adapted for
the for the stack so to fit these this
combination of features together with
the with this network we just modified
the layers to be to result in two for
convolutional layer followed by a drop
out and two fully connected layers which
would produce no linear combinations of
your output volume in cubic meters
yes the output is a logarithm of the
room volume so everything we decide to
express in as log so yeah moving on to
results these results are very fresh
they've been they just came yesterday
out of the oven today this morning yeah
all right so the first thing that we did
it's to train the model just on room
impose responses not to speech signals
because the the intuition is a we can
see just on normal impose responses
whether some features perform better
than others and should be technically an
easier problem than than speech signals
so we found out that generally in most
cases first of all having the Triton
data inside our set would improve
slightly the the results in almost all
situations the Gamma tone filter Bank
performed the best the M FCC is perform
really bad for some reason but we didn't
play too much with the parameters and
settings and the error metrics that
we're looking at in this table is well
the mean square error the correlation
factor and what has been called the mean
multiple or average multiple which Una's
came as a metric it's it's a way to say
how many times are we far from the real
volume so for example if it's 6.4 with
6.4 times either bigger or smaller than
the real volumes on average within the
test set so so and that metric is the
the mean taking the mean as the absolute
of the logarithm of the volume error by
point to mean
what means that on average our result is
within five point Q times bigger or
smaller than natural smoking could
difference two lies does it mean is that
you if you just use gamma tone filters
you get the best results bets better
even than the stock futures that was
true for the real for their room impose
responses for some reason but as we see
in the next slide is do not show up in
the speech scene but yeah it's it's an
interesting result we see actually Billy
at the T read this morning the saying
that you're just so moving on to the
speech signals this came in tonight
these are I'm going to first present the
most interesting results then we can go
deeper if the there's a people are
interested in in knowing all the cases
but in this case these are the results
on by using the oldest stack of features
that I showed earlier on the on the two
parallel sets we found without traction
and you can see that the results are
slightly better when the simulated data
is included in the in the training set
we obtained an a mean square error of
between 0-4 and to 0.6 correlation of
0.8 these are these these use the model
with the two fully connected layers
after four convolutional layers going
further we experimented with different
settings within the network so these are
actually the two best performing
situations by varying just some of the
layers we obtain an average multiple
error of 2.9 so this means we are 2.9
times of the real volume estimation so
you can see there's quite already from
the graft is quite a nice division
between the small rooms and the bigger
rooms that are in the test set these
small rooms they are harder to
distinguish from like refined changes
but at least you can get a nice
separation of small medium and large
diagonal diagonal would be ideal yeah
the x-axis it's true of the volume
versus estimated and you can see nine
vertical bars because we have nine
unique rooms in the test set seven from
this ace challenge and then to that we
just took from ice from one of the
databases so it was unless I
misunderstood the previous lighting
person to comparison finish you
seems like the error rate is lower here
yeah this is a harder problem there are
some there are some there are some
issues maybe with the the so we try to
use the same framework for generating
the noise signals as was used in today's
challenge but we applied that to noise
voice' fiying impulse responses and
that's not what the ACE challenge was
meant for so it looks at the impulse
response and says oh there's very little
energy in your signal which is just an
impulse response so I'm going to keep my
my noise level very low and so I don't
know those transients you put in
impulsive transients they give you a
very good estimate of the impulse
response can verify so instead of the
speech it might be locking on to there
was a lot of translate nuclear oh yes
the noise is also place will actually
give useful information to them yeah
they felt it was best for them yeah so
in the previous case we just had an
impulse response a signal yeah so here
you are certain more data actually the
date I think is to say well you buy
things right it was first seconds yeah
and what was the SNR this is all the
SNR's it says no branch yeah just
because I saw it so loan it's the front
zero plus 10 plus 20 and infinite which
means the studio recording SNR
were states like close my Kissin that
the actual speech signals were not very
focused okay not very highest possible
one one thing we didn't do here is we
should probably do that or for the paper
is use the actual ace evaluation set so
now we've used to now if use these rooms
that they recall it those actually
process concepts that don't appear in
our training set but we generated our
own speech signals in our own noisy
speech signals but they have recorded
those in a real rollin with real noise
so we should use that instead so
whatever transients were in there we can
we take advantage off if they are no
transition because now we see probably
that there is also probably a little bit
worse because there will be fewer
transients
there will be fewer transients I imagine
you know in a real evaluation set than
what we have here because we checked we
generated and randomly so we just put in
these never bits and bobs
but that's something we'll have to have
to do yep it also makes it easier to
reproduce you could just say abused
exactly that same dataset and just apply
this model to it to estimate what
yes so if I'm not gonna go through this
light very much but if you want to
discuss this later I'll happily bring it
up you can see they did just to explain
how this plot should be read intuitively
it is it is really bad this is the NFC
sees you can see that if everything is
on the line there's no they're not
really lying on the slope that we want
them to lie and it's not on this like in
a different slide I'll bring it up later
we have an example where the training
data leaked into the test set for some
reason and then you have at this amazing
prediction and this told us like how
much did it's important to keep a room
separate other situations so the the top
graphs they're all different
combinations or small modifications of
the network that I showed in the
previous slide the error is more or less
similar it gets worse
once you take single features one at a
time training later linked into the test
data but not to not in the sense that
the same data was there it was just the
same room up here to both places and
that was enough to get you really nice
results like even if even even though
you used different impulse responses so
it was a different impulse response of
different speech signal a different
noise signal but the same room in two
places unless a lot of prior work has
done that that they assumed that well
there are separate locations of their
independence but they're really quality
I was there you know so this is the the
result when you are back when the same
room leaked into the test that you have
this amazing
[Music]
one-point-six time within the real
volume mean square error of 0.1
correlation of 1 so this is too good to
be true because you have to bug first
right so you don't think oh we're done
yeah so I don't think it will qualify as
a true blind estimation in that case
yeah all right so going back to where we
left off
okay so future work discussions and
conclusions so there's a many areas of
improvement that we can think about so
the first the first thing that we can
think of is whether blind truly blind
estimation of room volume it's
necessarily the way to go I think if you
approach the problem from a
device-specific perspective you can you
can come up with semi-blind approaches
and make assumptions on some of the room
environment and sources by taking
advantage of other sensors present on
your device for example you can use a
beam forming on the toker to have a
reference so you can compare that
reference to other incoming signals make
some type of multi-channel correlation
feature attract extraction you could
think about tracking moving sources and
see how this changes for space maybe by
correlating that with camera image some
depth sensors in devices can give you
already some kind of a local mesh of
what's around you so these are this is
all food for thought for more precise
and tailored solutions data collection
can be improved by having more data of
course there was that gap that I showed
earlier and if
and perhaps if we covered the
distribution a little more evenly the
resource could get better there's this
pipeline could be reused potentially for
other parameters such as drr 260 in
frequency bands or the wet level that we
discussed in previous meetings this will
require the data to to be better
tailored for the task this is this is
the actually added a different way to
see our current situation
these are all our 84 view of rooms and
this is the volume in log scale every
time you see a jump it's data that is
missing it's something we don't have a
room covering this spanning what's in
between so it would be nice for this to
be as flat as possible so feature
extraction there's a lot of features
that we could explore and look better
for example the face spectrum we talked
about also like having some kind of
spectrogram of how does the incoming
phase behaved some echo density profiles
multi-channel features we're still not
entirely clear how the room information
can be isolated from other factors
because of course you have absorption
rates you have different degrees of
noise environments I don't know the
environments in the end we did they're
kind of similar settings you don't have
like multiple noise sources at different
distances maybe if you have one just
next to the two your microphone and
everything breaks so these are this
information is not really available in
literature right now and it's something
that should be more explored by having
simple experiments the network model we
we saw did not talk about this very much
but having a stacked features with
different unrelated features that should
not be convolved together mentally all
our convolution happen in one dimension
and not in two dimensions so maybe
perhaps there could be some kind of
hybrid network that could perform a 2d
convolution just on the gamut um part
and the one D on the others I don't know
whether that's possible or not too much
experience with this sort of problem but
it's something to look into
maybe the loss function can be changed
within the network to include some form
of perceptual tolerance how how bad
should the estimated label be compared
to the to the real volume so we don't
know it yet what's our tolerance and how
important is that we are close to the to
the real value and of course we can
always explore and change some of the
settings within our net current models
so further discussion is of course how
accurate do we need to be in estimating
room volumes there's be no preset to
studies that look to the room volume
discrimination J and E's well there has
been some studies for discrimination in
terms of classification but not in terms
of regressions so for example what if we
have a room with the same absorption
coefficient by different sizes what is
the J in D that we can discriminate the
size of this room this a lack of a
dataset able to isolate this parameter
from other elements right now so this
would be a good place to research to try
to understand how important is
perceptively the the estimation of the
room volume and if it's used to just
compute other parameters then the song
correlation should be drawn between the
the parameters estimated using the
volume using the estimated volume and
other forms obviously meeting the same
parameter
so that could tell you whether is worth
to use volume as a proxy for for example
the critical distance or just rethink
the whole thing and just try to estimate
the critical distance so the other
question is should this be in the first
place an audio problem well we know that
all these more generalizable for
different types of situations and
devices not just for mixed reality
headsets but computers laptops
telephones all sorts of technology
technological device that possesses a
microphone
computer vision can of course help to
estimate or cross validate the room size
estimation this is just an image front
end while you depth data said that it's
something that just to throw an idea of
how image could help labeling the size
of the room however then you start
introducing assumptions and you still
have to fight with the limitations of
actual technology like depth cameras
maybe don't go very far there are visual
obstacles maybe in your room and there's
there's another degree of error that you
will have to account for something that
has been as somebody once explained this
idea that if you could have just a cloud
server with the room size information of
all sorts of places that being cataloged
already by engineers and then you just
download your impulse response or your
device this this could be a different
way to go but going through the audio
approach was was Urkel so the
conclusions that we can draw from this
internship is a blind room volume
estimation is a hard problem a good
solution has not been yet found but some
insights were gained multiple feature
representations seem to be bringing
better results than just a single time
frequency representation and adding
simulating data did improve accuracy and
reduced the
average this multiple distance error so
so this also as a future outlook having
more Triton data or having maybe the
future iteration when maybe in atom work
is implemented together could even go
even bring more accurate simulations to
how to improve our data set still some
work at but to our knowledge is the
first regression model for the blind
estimation of room volume so this is
there was no baseline to compare against
and there's the see like a big space to
to move in sideways so that's that's
often positive similar framework as the
AC challenge makes the results more
comparable for future attempts a more
for for literature and the community is
a little more attractive and that would
be all thanks a lot thanks a lot to anis
because he helped me inside and outside
of the lab thanks to all the group I had
a really great time to be here this
summer effects the interest effects to
villa for visiting us and I hope our
interactions will continue in the future
thank you presentation one comment on
the features that was one of the last
slides where you mentioned echo that
echo density would be a good feature so
I think this is what mainly
characterizes the tearoom volume so
because he showed it you can have the
same reverberation time but different
room volumes and in a large room you
will have much less density effect
Austin
so but I think you can also determine
this from the frequency response because
you have more left more room modes or
more dips and you have a higher angular
density so this is probably the
strongest feature that you can use and
just as a idea for for future words it
would be probably so we saw you can
somehow estimate the reverberation time
so it would probably make sense to
jointly estimate reverberation time and
room volume and then it could go maybe
even further and also just have like
three or four outputs to even then
estimate the drr and/or probably the
source distance that you're probably
three four parameters if you can manage
them all together then probably us also
less confusions between room volume and
reverberation times something like this
and would really give a nice
characterization of the acoustic sensor
and I think maybe one comment on the
echo density unfortunately we can't
calculate that speech signals so for
impulse responses that would be great
yeah but you don't you don't need to - I
mean calculate specifically the equal
ten city but for example you can see
this and the frequency response of the
impulse response so you have more tips
yet more motes if you have a density I
guess I guess maybe to turn the question
around maybe echo density could be one
of the outputs yeah for example so in
general this is called multi stealth
training can if you force your network
to estimate stuff which you may not even
need this helps the network retain
better so I guess adding conditional
reverberation parameters on the output
can prove the room the room volume
itself even if you don't use the others
but realism the idea to connect 501st
hurts our lowest vertices and taking the
kids to Moulton what about today what
you say that the echo density brings or
how to do those echoes coming they kind
of change that makes the response the
new city that gets true
yes definitely a low-hanging fruit - to
implement just try and make me even even
just try only because responses and see
whatever we can we should follow this is
in the affirm so it keeps - may not be
that much useful but if you plot the
magnitude of this function at the time
so carefully cbons time very the frame
it may give you some some information
yeah speech signals definitely will be
better than just a single impulse
response so maybe maybe it's okay to
average you Tony it was response but yes
classic classic application of dish came
from analysis at least in the speech
front-end is you do averaging across the
time which presumably is the capital
filter in your subtracted and what's
left is the pure Sigma means removing
the impulse response between the source
and the microphone assuming that the
speech has basically zero average catch
term and then the only thing remains is
the impulse response that mean curl the
eventually useful because this is in
general the capture of the impulse
response
it was a question one yeah I think
already touched on it but a failure to
pass fear
it's from German Eldridge says if the
use case involves of materiality can we
not make use of room geometric info that
the headset is likely already
calculating for space striking and when
we still need to hear volume that we
clear and directly calculated or just
looking to supplementary find the source
right so I touched this earlier but we
wanted to generalize on something that
does not make assumptions about the
capability of a specific device but also
there is I mean me personally I don't
know much about how would such device
like a camera for example perform into
estimating volume if you have obstacles
around you or if you're facing a wall
you still have similar types of problems
that might occlude your vision so it
makes sense one that we want to try an
audio-only
situation
all right thanks a lot